this flag
does not represent me
good evening my name is Frank Rodriguez
and I'm the executive director of
operations for gays against groomers the
reason that I'm here is to show support
in regards to deciding to not fly the
gay flag during June I'm a 31 year old
gay man pushing back against the hijack
agenda of the LGBT Incorporated
the pride flag this flag
does not represent me when you're a
conservative gay and you have
conservative Traditional Values
it doesn't represent you
I am tired
I am tired of this community trying to
represent me and the millions of people
that support people like me gaze against
groomers represents millions of
like-minded LGBT members and the people
in this building are upset because they
think that they're being marginalized do
you see Chinese people in here upset
that we're not flying the Chinese flag
on Chinese New Year's or how about Cinco
de Mayo when the Mexicans got their
independence do you see Mexicans in here
upset no you see my community the gay
people that want to be marginalized that
make victims of ourselves this flag that
I'm standing on no longer represents me
this is not your fault I'm not yelling
at you I'm upset because people like
this are constantly representing my
community they make us look like fools
they make us look dumb and I'm tired of
it this flag does not represent everyone
with liberty and justice for all I I
love that he's doing so there's this
organization called gaze against
groomers I follow them on Twitter I try
to interact with them as much as I can
because I love the work that they're
doing they are out there saying get your
trans [__] away from kids and back it up
from us because we did not we never
called for this we wanted rights and
respect we got what we got what we
wanted and now you're now you're you've
latched on to our to our thing in order
to get in sexualized children and
mutilate children they're Furious and
they're growing in numbers gay people
are walking to this organization because
they're mortified by what do your gay
friends think about that stuff do they
do they like also agree that they
they're they're separate from like the P
plus honestly the gay friends that I'm
very close with I haven't had this
conversation with because since we moved
here I feel like that's an in-person
conversation that yeah not just on the
phone like so what do you think about
the trans yeah what do you think about
the trans and and you know do you think
it's time to burn your rainbow flag like
I don't it's not a phone call that's a
that's a bigger conversation for around
the kitchen table where that we can it's
like a late night chilling you're like
yeah what do you think about this [__]
you know and then you hit him with the
nice logic and then they're like yeah
has this come up you know yeah that's
one thing that's the way to do it but I
actually am really dying to know what
they think I mean they're all smart
people I don't see them disagreeing with
us they're all Beyond decent people some
of the best people I know there's no way
that they are on board with you know the
transiting of the children but they are
either not news inclined or inclined to
watch liberal news so they're not seeing
it the way we're seeing it so Bugs Bunny
cartoons bugs used to dress as a woman
all the time as a lady Bunny and when I
was a little kid and it was funny when
people are now putting out things like
that and going oh you never had a
problem with trans entertainment before
now all with drag before now all of a
sudden you do because it's political and
like no you [__] because they weren't
Bugs Bunny dressed as a woman making you
know just just having some fun playing
like trying to trick Elmer Fudd was not
did had nothing to to do with trying to
get me as a five-year-old to understand
sex and who am I attracted to and maybe
I want to cut off my body parts there
was none of that so when they use that
argument I'm like where do you even how
do you this is the best you got this is
the best argument you have we're getting
the direct shows that we watched the
other day with the the people those Bots
bringing their children their little
toddlers into into a drag show there's a
little girl going around the internet
now absolute NPCs a video video of about
a four or five-year-old girl at a drag
show and the drag queen is showing the
little girl how to move and the little
girl is trying to do all these sexy
moves and all the adults are just Joy
Overjoyed with themselves and laughing
it's that she's dancing with this grown
hairy man in sexy clothes it's
disgusting that flag this flag the
American Flag 13 stripes and 50 stars
represented
still standing there he's not clapping
for the American flag not this
and if the gay community would wake up
we wouldn't have this pushback stop
indoctrinating children and these types
of things wouldn't happen
[Applause]
hit him with the gay hands one more
thing hit him with the game do you know
where I can find a trash can
you find the little girl find the little
girl dancing with the drag queen let's
let's show the world where to find that
what do I look like Chachi BT this is so
weird
[Applause]
[Music]
you taking cash
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to watch this
[Applause]
and these people are cheering and
filming it and putting it on the
internet they're so proud
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
that's so creepy
just thinking about the scenario it's
just like so disgusting like when I've
like smoked weed in the past it makes me
think like whatever like action I'm
doing it's just like damn I'm really
doing this so like there was one time
where like we were all just like sitting
around the table with like all the ants
and I'm like huh like something that I
do with my time sometimes is I just like
sit with a bunch of 50 year old ladies
it's just like something I do and I'm
like this is hilarious that like I'm
here right now and like this is
something that these people do I
sometimes don't like simplify things to
maybe maybe I just sound like [__]
no you don't I guess like it's this is
something that people do like kind of go
swimming out on your own life a little
bit no that's what exactly what it is
you zoom out and you're like I can't
believe like this is like I'm filming of
like with my mom right now like I look
at this and I'm like this is it just
beats me bro it just beats me it's crazy
it's like it's crazy to think about when
you just like zoom out and look at like
the actual actions you're doing you're
just like what the [__]
I'm just like sitting here watching this
[__] like what and these people if they
zoomed out they would go I just ran up
and gave dollars to a little girl for
dancing sexy that's so rewarding for
dancing sexy it's just creepy it's like
it's like almost as if she's a stripper
but she's like four or whatever she is
like the handing the dollar bills I just
don't I don't understand that at all
it's just not she wanted to just like
dance people just think there's so
hilarious and so funny you know I mean I
just don't get it I just don't get how
this how involving children children in
this wait does the drag person come out
[Music]
[Applause]
of course little Nas is playing
cocaine he's shaking her little tush
look yeah look at this one on the right
cocaine and drinking with your friends
like this is just like
it's subconscious its subconscious
programming like that's I don't think
people understand like the food you eat
like if you eat a piece of bread it can
make you tired you know everything
around you essentially is what makes you
to some sense like if you're drinking
tap water or like some [__] that like
makes you dumber all the time or it has
a chemical in it that slows your brain
down it's gonna make you dumber so if
you're constantly shoved Like Cocaine
drinking with your friends and like
dollar bills thrown at you and this [__]
all the time like that has an impact on
children you know that's like the mate
that's the real Matrix when you really
step back you're like holy [__] all I am
is like and my me is I'm just a product
of my surroundings like the way I think
about like money and stuff it's like the
only reason I think about that is
because that's the environment I'm in
it's weird it you know here's the here's
the thing now this kid when she's you
know if she is ever God forbid alone or
in the company of a creepy uncle or
neighbor and he says hey Dan hey oh I've
got a few bucks dance for me like you
did in that video oh you know what I
mean mean like it just breaks down a
child's barriers and makes this normal
and the next thing you know she's being
molested yeah and that sounds like a
stretch before you say that but it's
really not it's just not because they
always do this [__] they take stuff way
too far every single time I've been
telling you this forever it started with
just like allow you know gay people and
everyone was like yeah that's fine and
then like each year they're just pushing
and pushing and pushing and now if you
don't want to have sex with a trans
woman you're transphobic like that oh
yeah that's where we've gone that's the
stuff that I can't stand now but this is
like legit girls my age that I think
that that is insane that's insane
[Music]
oh
guys
[Music]
what the hell is that thing in the
background
[Music]
[Applause]
or makeup or whatever it is in a beard
this looks like a Star Wars Episode it's
like one of those like weird planets
that's about to get blown up because
they're just too Haram there's just like
weird aliens running around in the
background kids dancing for money maybe
we're that little planet that that star
is going to come and just below us all
it has such a higher chance of having
trouble in her future if this is what
she's going to be a part of think about
it like what what guys like it's just
ruining her it's sad it is sad damn I
couldn't imagine if that was my daughter
on a positive note back to the beginning
of the video the gays the you know the
gay community is coming out and at least
and fighting back so the gay community
is now separating and joining the rest
of us and saying we are not having this
the the flap back that this woke
[__] because this is just one sliver
one layer of the woke [__] that that
they are get going to get they don't
even know they are so still and they're
like la land of wokism that they can't
even see the tsunami coming at them of
people who have had it and we're done
with all of it take your racism take
your transgenderism take your child
grooming and stick it all up your ass
we're not in your socialism in your
communism stick it up your ass we're not
having it stick it up your ass kid go
drink a water not having it it's over
you you or it's close to over enjoy your
last hurray your last trip around
walking here stick it up yes all right
thank you so much for watching make sure
to like subscribe follow me on Instagram
follow me on Twitter
nope just no and join my Discord and see
you later
[Music]